THANK YOU, TUCKER.
BUCKLE UP.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
WE BEGIN TONIGHT WITH A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
THE WITCH HUNT IS OFFICIALLY
OVER.
THE MUELLER REPORT IS OUT. THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
HAS BEEN TOTALLY AND COMPLETELY
VINDICATED.
WATCH THIS?
>> I'M HAVING A GOOD DAY TOO.
IT'S CALLED NO CONCLUSIO
IT'S CALLED NO COLLLUSIO
IT'S CALLED NO COLLUSSIO
IT'S CALLED NO COLLUSIOO
IT'S CALLED NO COLLUSION, NO
OBSTRUCTION.
[ APPLAUSE ]
THERE NEVER WAS, BY THE WAY, AND
THERE NEVER WILL BE.
AND WE DO HAVE TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF THESE THINGS, I WILL
SAY.
AND THIS SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN.
THIS SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN TO
ANOTHER PRESIDENT AGAIN. THIS
HOAX, IT SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN TO
ANOTHER PRESIDENT AGAIN.
>> WE'RE GOING TO DO OUR PART TO
MAKE SURE IT DOESN'T HAPPEN
AGAIN.
WE'RE HOLDING THOSE PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE.
WE HAVE A LOT TO GET TO TONIGHT.
BUT FOR THE PAST 2 1/2 YEARS,
THE LEADER OF THE FREE WORLD WAS
FORCED TO DEDICATE SO MUCH
PRECIOUS TIME, ENERGY,
RESOURCES, TO AN UNJUST
INVESTIGATION SURROUNDING WHAT
IS A HOAX.
HERE'S THE BOTTOM LINE DIRECTLY
FROM THE MUELLER REPORT.
QUOTE, THE INVESTIGATION DID NOT
ESTABLISH THAT MEMBERS OF THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN CONSPIRED OR
COORDINATED WITH THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT IN ITS ELECTION
INTERFERENCE ACTIVITIES. THE
PRESIDENT'S TEAM OF LAWYERS ARE
RIGHTFULLY TRIUMPHANT WRITING,
QUOTE, THE RESULTS OF THE
INVESTIGATION ARE A TOTAL
VICTORY FOR THE PRESIDENT, THE
REPORT UNDERSCORES WHAT WE HAVE
ARGUED FROM THE VERY BEGINNING,
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION, THERE
WAS NO OBSTRUCTION.
IT IS CLEAR THERE WAS NO
CRIMINAL WRONGDOING, NOTHING
WITHHELD, NOTHING CONCEALED, OH,
NOTHING DELETED, NOTHING
DESTROYED, AND NOTHING BLEACHED.
THAT'S RIGHT, NO BLEACH PIT,
UNLIKE HILLARY CLINTON.
THE PRESIDENT DIDN'T DESTROY
SUBPOENAED E-MAILS OR ANY OTHER
EVIDENCE IN THIS CASE.
HE DID NOT INVOKE EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE.
INSTEAD, ACCORDING TO
INDEPENDENT COUNSEL, KEN STARR,
THE PRESIDENT'S COOPERATION IN
THIS CASE WAS UNPRECEDENTED AND
THAT'S BECAUSE PRESUMPTUOUS HAD
NOTHING TO HIDE.
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
DOCUMENTS WERE TURNED OVER,
ALMOST 1.4 MILLION, UNFETTERED
ACCESS GIVEN TO TRUMP CAMPAIGN,
OFFICIALS, ADMINISTRATION
EMPLOYEES.
MUELLER'S TEAM COMPLETED 30
HOURS OF INTERVIEWS WITH THE
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL.
HOW DOES THAT HAPPEN?
NO EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE WAS USED
TO HIDE ANYTHING IN MUELLER'S
REPORT. BY CONTRAST, THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, THEY USED
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE TO WITHHOLD
20 E-MAILS FROM THEN ATTORNEY
GENERAL ERIC HOLDER SURROUNDING
HIS INVOLVEMENT IN THE FAST AND
FURIOUS GUN-RUNNING SCANDAL.
WELL, THAT WAS A REAL SCANDAL.
WHEREAS TRUMP, RUSSIA,
COLLUSION, WAS A FARCE.
TONIGHT, THANKFULLY FOR THE SAKE
OF THIS COUNTRY, TRUTH HAS
PREVAILED.
AS THE PRESIDENT'S ATTORNEYS PUT
IT, QUOTE, THIS VINDICATION OF
THE PRESIDENT IS AN IMPORTANT
STEP FORWARD FOR THE COUNTRY AND
A STRONG REMINDER THAT THIS TYPE
OF ABUSE MUST NEVER BE PERMITTED
TO OCCUR AGAIN. NOW, COMING UP
IN THE MONOLOGUE.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE YOU THROUGH
THE REAL CRIMES THAT WILL BE
EXPOSED.
WE'RE GOING TO CALL OUT ALL OF
THE DEMOCRATS, THE MEDIA MOB WHO
HAVE SPENT 2.5 YEARS LYING,
DEFRAUDING, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND MARK MY WORDS, AN AVALANCHE
OF TRUTH AND JUSTICE IS ABOUT TO
BURY ALL OF THOSE WHO ABUSE
THEIR POWER.
2 1/2 YEARS, NEVER ENDING.
NONSTOP.
TINFOIL CONSPIRACY THEORISTS,
AND THE MEDIA MOB OBSESSED AT A
LEVEL OF PSYCHOSIS WE'VE NEVER
SEEN.
EVERY DAY, RUSSIA, RUSSIA,
RUSSIA, COLLUSION, COLLUSION,
COLLUSION.
AFTER FOUR SEPARATE
INVESTIGATIONS, INCLUDING A
NINE-MONTH FBI INVESTIGATION, A
HOUSE INTEL INVESTIGATION, A
BIPARTISAN INVESTIGATION IN THE
SENATE, AND NOW THE ALL-POWERFUL
MUELLER PROBE, WE KNOW ZERO
TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION. GLEN
GREEN WALD PUT IT WELL.
ROBERT MUELLER DID NOT MERELY
REJECT THE TRUMP-RUSSIA
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, HE
OBLITERATED THEM.
THIS TODAY MARK THIS DAY THE
BIGGEST BEAT DOWN THE MEDIA MOB
HAS EXPERIENCED IN HISTORY.
BECAUSE EVERY TIME THEY
MENTIONED RUSSIA, RUSSIA,
RUSSIA, EVERY TIME THEY SAID
COLLUSION, COLLUSION, COLLUSION,
WE THOUSAND KNOW IT WAS A LIE.
2 1/2 YEARS OF LIE AFTER LIE
AFTER LIE, CONSPIRACY THEORIES
POSING AS NEWS PROGRAMS.
BY THE WAY, HOW STUPID MUST
RACHAEL MADDOW AND HER BLAND
BAND OF BLITHEERRING CONSPIRACY
THEORISTS FEEL TODAY?
IN A MOMENT, WE'RE GOING TO SHOW
YOU THESE THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOU DID.
NOW, BACK TO MY MONOLOGUE.
AS I SAID FOR 2 1/2 YEAR, YOU,
WE, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, YOU
HAVE BEEN THE VICTIMS OF THE
BIGGEST CON JOB IN AMERICAN
HISTORY, EVERY SECOND, EVERY
HOUR, EVERY DAY.
THE DEMOCRATS, THE HATE TRUMP
MEDIA MOB, ALL OTHERS,
PERPETRATING A LIE, EVERY TIME
THEY SAID RUSSIA, RUSSIA,
RUSSIA, COLLUSION, COLLUSION,
THEY WERE SMEARING, BESMIRCHING,
SLANDERING, TRYING TO UNDO AN
ELECTION, A DULY ELECTED
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
ALL DAY, EVERY DAY, RUSSIA,
RUSSIA, COLLUSION, COLLUSION,
JUST TO TAKE YOU DOWN MEMORY
LANE AND REMIND YOU OF THESE
LIES, NONSTOP CONSPIRACY
THEORIES AND LIES..
>> WE'RE ABOUT TO FIND OUT IF
THE NEW PRESIDENT OF OUR COUNTRY
IS GOING TO DO WHAT RUSSIA WANTS
AS IF THERE ARE NO SHOES ON THE
TRUMP HUMAN CENTIPEDE THAT ARE
NOT ABOUT RUSSIA. RUSSIA,
RUSSIA.
>> THIS CLOUD OF COLLUSION WITH
RUSSIA WILL HANG OVER HIM NO
MATTER WHERE HE STANDS HE MAY BE
THE FIRST PRESIDENT IN QUITE
SOMETIME TO FACE THE REAL
PROSPECT OF JAIL TIME THEY'RE
SHOCKED THAT THE NOOSE IS
TIGHTENING IT'S CLEAR THAT
MUELLER IS NOW CONNECTING THE
DOTS BETWEEN A MASSIVE
OBSTRUCTION INTENDED TO HIDE THE
TRUTH THIS PRESIDENT NEEDS TO BE
IMPEACHED.
I BELIEVE THAT.
I BELIEVE THERE WAS COLLUSION.
>> DONALD TRUMP'S DONE.
HE'S DONE. THERE'S NO QUESTION
ABOUT IT.
>> HE'S GOT TO KNOW HIS FUTURE
LOOKS LIKE IT'S BEHIND BARS WE
HAVE A TREASONED PRESIDENT.
>> HE FEELS THE WORLD IS CLOSING
IN ON HIM.
HE'S DONE WHAT HE CAN IN
TRASHING THE SPECIAL COUNSEL MR.
TRUMP IS SEEING MORE AND MORE OF
THE WALLS CLOSING IN ON HIM
WHICH IS WHY HE'S BECOMING
INCREASINGLY DESPERATE.
>> WHOO! IF HE FIRES ANY SECRET
SERVICE AGENT WHO WOULD ALLOW
THE FEDERAL MARSHAL IN.
WHAT IF DONALD TRUMP SIMPLY
DECIDES I DON'T HAVE TO FLOW THE
LAW.
I REFUSE TO BE HELD UNDER THE
NO MARSHAL CAN GET INTO THIS
WHITE HOUSE UNBELIEVABLE
CONSPIRACY THEORIES LIES.
THEY BETRAY THEIR AUDIENCE.
THEY DON'T CARE AT ALL ABOUT THE
TRUTH.
LOOK AT WHAT THEY DID.
LOOK AT WHAT THEY DID TO A
16-YEAR-OLD, NIKOLA SANDMAN
TRYING TO DESTROY A 16-YEAR-OLD
KID WITH NOTHING BUT BASELESS
LIES.
THEY DIDN'T MAKE ONE PHONE CALL
TO TRY TO CONFIRM THE STORY.
THEY MAKE IT UP AND THEY
BLUDGEON A 16-YEAR-OLD KID FOR
WEARING A MAGA HAT.
THAT'S HOW MUCH THESE PEOPLE IN
THE MEDIA, IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, HATE TRUMP.
THERE WAS NO BASIC RESEARCH IN
THE CASE OF JUSSIE SMOLLETT.
DON'T FORGET THE I BELIEVERS
WHEN IT CAME TO JUSTICE CAV
NALL, OR WHEN THEY SET OUT TO
DESTROY, GO BACK TO RICHARD
JEWELL, THE DUKE LACROSSE KIDS,
THE STUDENTS AT THE CENTER OF
THE FAKE UVA RAPE CASE, THE
CAMBRIDGE SMEAR, THE FERGUSON
POLICE OFFICER, DARREN WILSON,
GUILT BY THE MEDIA, ACCUSATION.
THE BALTIMORE POLICE, GUILT BY
ACCUSATION.
ON EVERY ONE OF THOSE CASES, WE
WERE RIGHT, THEY WERE WRONG.
WE SAW IT OVER AND OVER AGAIN ON
TRUMP, RUSSIA, COLLUSION,
COLLUSION.
FALSE REPORTS THAT DON JR. WOULD
BE FOUND GUILTY OF CRIMES, DEREK
KUSHNER, GUILTY, MELANIA, OTHER
FAMILY MEMBERS SMEARED,
BESMIRCHED AT EVERY TURN BY
SANCTIMONIOUS, SELF-RIGHTEOUS,
OVERPAID LAZY OPINION-DRIVEN
LIARS IN THE NEWS MEDIA,
CONSPIRACY THEORISTS.
NO SHAME WHATSOEVER.
WHAT ARE THE APOLOGIES, THE
RETRACTIONS, THE CORRECTIONS?
NOWHERE TO BE FOUND.
JUST THE OPPOSITE.
NOW DOUBLE DOWN ON HYSTERIA,
RECKLESS, RECKLESS REPORTING.
NOW IT'S OBSTRUCTION,
OBSTRUCTION.
IF MUELLER COULD, HE AND HIS
PARTNERS AND TEAM OF DEMOCRATIC
DONORS AND HILLARY LOVERS, THEY
WOULD HAVE FOUND CRIMES.
BUT NOW WITH ZERO INTROSPECTION,
NO SELF-REFLECTION, NO APOLOGY,
IT'S JUST ON LIKE IT NEVER
HAPPENED.
LET'S GO TO THE NEXT PACK OF
LIES, THE NEXT ROUND OF
BREATHLESS REPORTING, THE NEXT
MANUFACTURERED SCANDAL TO
DESTROY TRUMP, A PSYCHOTIC RAGE
IN EVERY SO-CALLED NEWSROOM IN
AMERICA, ALL WHILE IGNORING
SIMULTANEOUSLY WHAT IS THE
BIGGEST STORY IN THEIR CAREERS
AND LIFETIME BECAUSE OF THEIR
BLIND ADHERENCE TO RIGID LEFT
WING LOVING HILLARY IDEOLOGY.
SO IT'S NO SHOCK THAT JUST AS WE
PREDICTED YESTERDAY, THE MEDIA
MOB AND THEIR ECK CO-CHAMBER ARE
BACK IN ACTION WITH ONE LAST
FULL ON HYSTERICAL FREAKOUT OVER
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
THIS IS A SAD DISTURBING GRAND
FINALE.
BUT IT'S NOW BEEN OVER TWO YEARS
OF THIS -- THIS LYING CAMPAIGN
TO DESTROY A PRESIDENT. OF
COURSE, WE THE PEOPLE, THE
SMELLY WALMART VOTERS WHO CLINK
TO OUR GOD, GUNS, AND RELIGION,
THE
TOR REDEEMABLES AND
DEPLORABLES, DON'T THINK THEY
LIKE US ANY BETTER THIS IS AN
INVESTIGATION AT ITS CORE ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP'S DAILY, SOMETIMES
HOURLY ASSAULT ON THE RULE OF
LAW IN THIS COUNTRY.
AS THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE, HE SAT
IN HIS PAJAMAS WATCHING FOX &
FRIENDS MALIGNING THE FBI.
BILL DIDN'T WALK INTO THAT ROOM
WITH A SCALE OF 0.
RULE OF LAW HAD A DEFICIT
BECAUSE DONALD TRUMP HAD BEEN
KICKING IT IN THE TEETH.
>> CAN I JUST TALK ABOUT THIS
ISSUE OF THE PRESIDENT'S
CONCERNS ABOUT LEAKS?
YOU KNOW WHO ELSE WAS CONCERNED
ABOUT LEAKS?
RICHARD NIXON?
>> THIS REPORT IS A GIFT TO THE
GOVERNMENT OF RUSSIA.
THIS IS A VERY PROUD MOMENT FOR
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> THE AMOUNT OF INFORMATION
THAT RELATES TO COLLUSION AND
OBSTRUCTION ACTIVITY, IS REALLY
QUITE EXTENSIVE IN THIS.
>> THERE'S SIGNIFICANT --
THERE'S SIGNIFICANT MATERIAL IN
HERE THAT WE DID NOT KNOW ON THE
QUESTION OF COLLUSION.
IT'S HERE IN SUBSTANCE, IN
NUANCE.
IN CONTEXT. AND IT'S THERE FOR
ALL PEOPLE OF GOODWILL IN THIS
COUNTRY IF THEY'RE NOT SO DUG IN
POLITICALLY OR I'D LOGICALLY TO
PROCESS THE INFORMATION AND MAKE
SOME SOPHISTICATED JUDGMENTS AND
THE OTHER THING THIS REPORT DID
WAS IT CORROBORATE ADD LOT OF
THE GOOD JOURNALISM THAT WAS
DONE MUELLER HIGHLY RESPECTED
INVESTIGATOR AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIAL.
HE COULD NOT FIND SUFFICIENT
EVIDENCE THAT THERE WAS
CONSPIRACY BY ANY AMERICAN OR
ANY MEMBER OF THE TRUMP TEAM.
THAT'S GREAT NEWS. BARR
REPEATING IT OVER AND OVER AND
OVER AGAIN SIX OR SEVEN TIMES,
THAT'S EXCESSIVE.
>> Sean: YOU CAN SEE, MORE AND
MORE FAKE NEWS AND SOME
COLLUSION TRUTHERS DESPERATELY
CLINGING ON TO A TOTALLY FAKE
CLAIM.
OTHERS, THEY'RE SHIFTING THE
NARRATIVE TO OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE OR THE PRESIDENT'S
TAXES.
THE PRESIDENT WAS NOT CHARGED.
HE WAS CLEARED OF OBSTRUCTION.
NOT BY MUELLER, NOT BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE UNITED
STATES WHO EMPHASIZED TODAY THAT
OBSTRUCTION JUST DID NOT OCCUR.
IT DID NOT. SORRY.
>> THE REPORT RECOUNTS 10
EPISODES INVOLVING THE PRESIDENT
AND DISCUSSES POTENTIAL LEGAL
THEORIES FOR CONNECTING THOSE
ACTIVITIES TO THE ELEMENTS OF AN
OBSTRUCTION OFFENSE.
AFTER CAREFULLY REVIEWING THE
FACTS AND LEGAL THEORIES OUTLINE
FACTS AND LEGAL THEORIES OUTLI E
OUTLINED IN THE REPORT, AND IN
CONSULTATION OF THE OFFICE OF
LEGAL COUNSEL AND OTHER
DEPARTMENT LAWYERS, THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND I CONCLUDED
THAT THE EVIDENCE DEVELOPED BY
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL IS NOT
SUFFICIENT TO ESTABLISH THAT THE
PRESIDENT COMMITTED AN
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE OFFENSE.
>> Sean: TOP LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIAL IN THE U.S., THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL, ATTORNEY
GENERAL, THE OFFICE OF LEGAL
COUNSEL ALL AGREE, NO
OBSTRUCTION, NO COLLUSION.
YES, THE PRESIDENT TALKED ABOUT
THE WAYS TO CURTAIL THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL INVESTIGATION.
YEAH, I'M SURE IT WAS
FRUSTRATING.
YEAH, HE DISCUSSED FIRING
MUELLER, THE PRESIDENT HOPE
OPENLY HOPING THAT LIEUTENANT
GENERAL FLYNN WOULD NOT FACE
CHARGES.
YES, THE PRESIDENT EXPRESSED
FRUSTRATION AND ANGER THAT HIS
PRESIDENCY WAS BEING BURDENED
WITH AN INVESTIGATION WHICH IS A
HOAX.
YOU KNOW, TALKING, THINKING,
TWEETING, THEY ARE NOT CRIMES.
IF THE PRESIDENT WANTED TO SINK
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
INVESTIGATION, HE HAD ARTICLE 2
AUTHORITY UNDER THE
CONSTITUTION.
HE COULD HAVE PERSONALLY FIRED
ROBERT MUELLER OR ANYONE ELSE
FOR THAT MATTER.
THE PRESIDENT DID NOT FIRE
MUELLER OR ROSENSTEIN OR WISEMAN
OR G.D. RAY OR ANY OTHER CLINTON
DONORS AND ALLIES INVESTIGATING
THIS SHAM, THIS CAMPAIGN.
THE PRESIDENT TOOK NO ACTION TO
IMPEDE THE PROSECUTION OF
LIEUTENANT GENERAL FLYNN OR PAUL
MANAFORT OR GEORGE POPADAPOLOUS
OR ANYONE ELSE. THE PRESIDENT
ENGAGED IN AN UNPRECEDENTED
LEVEL OF COOPERATION WITH THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL AND ABOVE ALL
ELSE, THERE WAS NO UNDERLYING
CRIME. NONE. 2 1/2 YEARS.
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, COLLUSION,
COLLUSION, NOW, ALL LIES.
IT SHOULD TAKE THIS COUNTRY'S
COLLECTIVE BREATH AWAY. AND
ACCORDING TO MUELLER'S REPORT,
IN 2017, THE PRESIDENT REACTED
TO THE APPOINTMENT OF THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL, QUOTE, OH, MY
GOD, THIS IS TERRIBLE.
THIS IS THE END OF MY
PRESIDENCY.
I'M BLEEPED. BUT, THE
PRESIDENT -- BUT PRESIDENT TRUMP
DIDN'T SAY THAT BECAUSE HE WAS
GUILTY OF HIS CRIME.
READ A LITTLE FURTHER.
IT WAS ABOUT CONCERNS ABOUT HOW
WILL IMPACT AND AFFECT HIS
PRESIDENCY AND THE COUNTRY.
QUOTE, EVERYONE TELLS ME, IF YOU
GET ONE OF THESE INDEPENDENT
COUNSELS, IT RUINS YOUR
PRESIDENCY.
IT TAKES YEARS AND YEARS AND I
WON'T BE ABLE TO DO ANYTHING.
THAT'S WHERE HIS THOUGHT PROCESS
WAS.
AND ACTUALLY, CONTEXT MATTERS,
DOESN'T IT?
THE PRESIDENT IS NOT BEING
CHARGED WITH OBSTRUCTION BECAUSE
OBSTRUCTION DIDN'T EXIST.
NOW THE MEDIA MOB LASHING OUT
ONE LAST TIME, AND AT THE END OF
THE NEW ATTORNEY GENERAL WILLIAM
BARR BECAUSE HE WON'T DO THEIR
BIDDING.
MORE PSYCHOTIC RAGING FROM YOUR
FRIENDS IN THE FAKE NEWS
INDUSTRY.
THEY CAN'T HELP THEMSELVES.
IT IS A MASS PSYCHOSIS AT THIS
POINT.
>> AT THE AGE OF 68, BILL BARR
HAS DECIDED HIS LEGACY HE IS
FINE WITH HIS LEGACY BEING THE
AG WHO TOOK ONE FOR THE TEAM.
>> WE WOULD NOT BE SURPRISED IF
SOME HEADLINE WRITER SOMEWHERE
CAME UP WITH BAGHDAD BILL BARR
FOR WHAT WE SAW TODAY IT WAS
EXCESSIVE AND SUSPICIOUS.
>> MR. BARR VIOLATED ALL OF THE
NORMS THAT HAD BEEN ESTABLISHED
POST WATERGATE AND TOOK US BACK
TO NIXONIAN TYPE THINGS I
REACHED A POINT WHERE I JUST
WROTE DOWN, BARR CONTINUES TO
SHILL FOR THE PRESIDENT
SOMETIMES YOU CAN HAVE AN
ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO'S JUST
COMPROMISED FOR ONE REASON OR
THE OTHER.
>> REAL, BRIAN WILLIAMS?
YOU'RE THE SAME GUY THAT SAW
DEAD BODIES IN KATRINA IN AREAS
WHERE THERE'S NO WATER?
YOU'RE GOING TO LECTURE ANYBODY?
COME UP WITH A FEW NAMES FOR
YOU.
ANY OF THESE PEOPLE CONCERNED
WITH OBSTRUCTION.
OKAY, WHY DID THEY IGNORE THE
BIGGEST SLAM DUNK CASE OF
OBSTRUCTION IN MODERN HISTORY?
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN AS WE TOLD
YOU LAST NIGHT, HILLARY CLINTON,
SHE DID COMMIT AN UNDERLYING
CRIME, A CLEAR VIOLATION OF THE
ESPIONAGE ACT WE KNOW FOR A
FACT, IT'S INCONTROVERTIBLE.
SHE STORED CLASSIFIED TOP SECRET
INFORMATION MARKED AS SUCH ON AN
UNSECURED SERVER.
SHE DELETED THEN 33,000
SUBPOENAED E-MAILS.
SHE ACID WASHED HER HARD DRIVES
WITH BLEACH PIT, SHE REMOVED THE
SIM CARDS, HAD AIDES DESTROY
DEVICES, BLACKBERRIES, WITH A
HAMMER.
SHE HAD INTENT CRUCIAL TO THE
CRIME THAT WAS COMMITTED AND THE
INTENT WAS TO DESTROY THE
EVIDENCE.
BUT NOW, EQUAL JUSTICE IS
COMING.
PAY CLOSE ATTENTION BECAUSE WHAT
WE'RE ABOUT TO PLAY OUT HERE IN
FRONT OF AMERICA IN THE COMING
DAYS, WEEKS, AND MONTHS, IS
EVERYTHING THAT WE'VE BEEN
TELLING YOU.
THE CLINTON E-MAIL INVESTIGATION
IS NOW BEING PROBED BY SENATOR
LINDSEY GRAHAM BECAUSE THE FIX
WAS IN.
THAT INVESTIGATION WAS RIGGED.
CRIMINAL REFERRALS FROM THE DEEP
STATE OPERATIVES THAT TRIED TO
HELP TO ELECT HILLARY CLINTON,
GIVING HER A PASS ON A CRIME SHE
COMMITTED.
YEAH, THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE
CRIMINAL REFERRALS FROM DEVIN
NUNEZ.
AND THE HOROWITZ FISA
INVESTIGATION.
THE BULK OF THAT INFORMATION IN
THE FISA APPLICATION, HILLARY
CLINTON'S BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
THE INVESTIGATION IS GOING ON
ABOUT LEAKING.
NOW THE PRESIDENT LAST TIME WE
INTERVIEWED HIM RIGHT HERE ON
THE PROGRAM, THE FBI'S 302s
CONVERSATIONS, CHRISTOPHER
STEELE, BRUCE ORR, ETC.
THEY WILL BE COMING OUT.
YES, THE FISA APPLICATIONS
AGAINST CARTER PAGE, THE BULK OF
INFORMATION, HILLARY'S BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR RUSSIAN LIES,
THEY'RE ALL COMING OUT.
THE GANG OF EIGHT INFORMATION,
FBI ADMITTING WRONGDOING IN SOME
OF THAT I'M TOLD.
AND FOR ALL OF YOU DEMOCRATS,
YOU UH CLAIM TO LOVE
TRANSPARENCY, BUCKLE UP.
YOU'RE ABOUT TO GET WHAT YOU'VE
BEEN WISHING FOR.
AND IT WON'T PAINT A PRETTY
PICTURE IN ANY WAY OF YOUR
FRIENDS IN THE DEEP STATE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT YOU, LORETTA
LYNCH, CLEARLY YOU INTERFERED IN
THE CLINTON E-MAIL
INVESTIGATION.
WE NOW KNOW THAT INVESTIGATION
WAS COMPLETELY RIGGED TO SAVE
HILLARY FROM BEING INDICTED.
YOU KNOW, THE MATTER, NOT THE
INVESTIGATION.
AND WE'RE NOT JUST TALKING ABOUT
THE SECRET MEETING ON THE TARMAC
WITH BILL CLINTON DAYS BEFORE
THE DECISION, OR THE TIME YOU
INSTRUCTED COMEY TO CALL IT A
MATTER NOT UNDER INVESTIGATION.
LOOK AT THESE NEWLY RELEASED
TRANSCRIPT, CLOSED DOOR
TESTIMONY, EVEN STRUCK AND PAGE,
THEY'RE ADMITTING THE D.O.J.
CONTROLLED ALL OF THIS, RIGGING
THE CLINTON PROBE FROM THE
BEGINNING.
THEY KNEW THE FIX WAS IN.
SO WHAT DOES LORETTA LYNCH KNOW,
WHEN DID SHE KNOW IT.
WHERE'S HER E-MAIL AND TEXT
MESSAGES. WHY DID AN UNMASKING
REQUEST IN ELECTION YEAR 2016
INCREASE ALMOST 350% UNDER HER
WATCH?
WHAT DID RICE KNOW?
WHEN DID SHE KNOW IT?
WHY WOULD THE UN AMBASSADOR
SAMANTHA POWERS REQUEST, OH, 100
UNMASKINGS AND SAY OH, I DIDN'T
REALLY REQUEST THAT?
SHE DIDN'T, WHO DID?
WE GO TO OUR GOOD FRIEND, THE
MAN WHO STANDS ABOVE IT ALL,
JAMES COMEY. WHY DID HE SIGN OFF
ON THAT FIRST FISA WARRANT IN
OCTOBER OF 2016 TO SPY ON THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATE CARTER
PAGE, USING HILLARY'S BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR PHONY RUSSIAN DOSSIERS,
THE BULK OF EVIDENCE.
THAT MEANS HE'S SIGNING OFF THAT
IT'S TRUE AND ACCURATE TO THE
BEST OF HIS KNOWLEDGE.
WE NOW KNOW IT WAS NEVER
VERIFIED.
AND WE KNOW IT'S UNVERIFIABLE
BECAUSE CHRISTOPHER STEELE
DOESN'T EVEN STAND BY HIS OWN
DOSSIER.
REMEMBER, HE TOLD THE TRUMP --
DONALD TRUMP, PRESIDENT-ELECT AT
THE TIME WHEN HE WENT TO TRUMP
TOWER THAT THE CONTENTS OF THE
DOSSIER WAS SALACIOUS AND
UNVERIFIED.
YET, THREE MONTHS BEFORE, HE
WENT BEFORE A FISA JUDGE AND
SAID THE DOSSIER WAS TRUE AND
CORRECT. THREE MONTHS EARLIER.
SO THE QUESTION FOR JIM COMEY
TONIGHT WAS DID YOU LIE IN
OCTOBER OF 2016 OR JANUARY OF
2017.
AND BY THE WAY, WHY DID SALLY
YATES AND DAVID AVONTE AND ROD
ROSENSTEIN WHO SIGNED UP ON THE
LAST FISA WARRANT?
WHY DID THEY SIGN OFF ON
UNVERIFIABLE. WERE THEY
TRAFFICKING THE DIRTY DOSSIER
THROUGHOUT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
BY THE WAY, WHO LEAKED IT TO
ISIKOFF, DAVID CORN, "THE
WASHINGTON POST"?
DID THEY LEAK IT TO IMPACT AN
ELECTION WITH RUSSIAN LIES, TO
BLUDGEON THE PRESIDENT-ELECT?
WHO TOLD HARRY REID?
AND LET'S NOT FORGET STRUCK AND
PAGE AND THE HIGH-RANKING FBI
OFFICIALS WHO RIGGED THE WHOLE
INVESTIGATION INTO CLINTON
BECAUSE SHE WAS THE FAVORED
CANDIDATE THAT SHOULD WIN 100
MILLION TO 0.
THE PEOPLE VOTING FOR TRUMP LIKE
ME AND YOU, WE WERE JUST SMELLY
WALMART SHOPPERS.
SO MANY QUESTIONS WILL BE
ANSWERED NOW THAT WE KNOW THAT
WE'RE SPIES INSIDE THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN. HERE'S ANOTHER
QUESTION.
WAS THERE ANY OUTSOURCING OF
INTELLIGENCE GATHERING?
AND IN OTHER WORDS, WERE THERE
ANY EFFORTS BY HIGH-RANKING
MEMBERS OF OUR INTEL COMMUNITY
TO BYPASS AMERICAN LAWS AND
MAYBE USE OUR BRITISH,
AUSTRALIA, ITALIAN SPY FRIENDS
TO SURVEIL THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
AND BY THE WAY, WHO GOT TO STEP
ON HALPER.
WHO TASKED HIM TO COVERTLY MEET
WITH POPADOPOLUS AND CARTER
PAGE.
AND BY THE WAY, WHO RECRUITED
HIM FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THIS CLEARLY HAPPENED.
IF ANY OF THIS HAPPENED BEFORE
JULY 31, THE ALLEGED BEGINNING
OF THE FBI'S COLLUSION
INVESTIGATION, WE NEED TO KNOW
WHEN IT STARTED.
AND FINALLY, WE NEED TO KNOW
THIS BIG QUESTION -- WHAT DID HE
KNOW?
WHAT DID PRESIDENT OBAMA KNOW?
AND WHEN DID HE KNOW IT?
ALL OF THIS HAPPENED UNDER HIS
WATCH. HERE'S WHAT'S COMING --
HERE'S WHAT I PREDICT IS COMING
IN THE DAYS, WEEKS, AND MONTHS
AHEAD.
WE'LL GET ANSWERS TO ALL OF
THESE PRESSING QUESTIONS.
THE HATE TRUMP MEDIA MOB
DEMOCRATS DEEP STATE, THEY WILL
GET BURNED WITH A BARRAGE, AN